5.7 billion dollars is a lot of money and while some propose it go towards a wall, or gate thing,
we started wondering what else can you buy with
5.7 billion dollars? Well, if you're feeling hungry, you could buy 34.2 billion strawberries.
Or maybe you're looking for something a little less healthy, like 1.14 billion Big Macs.
Of course, the cost to fix Flint Michigan's water pipes is
estimated at 55 million dollars, so they could be fixed 103 times. Speaking of health,
we could fully vaccinate 2.6 million children from birth to age 18
which could have prevented every death caused by Tuberculosis, Hepatitis B, Whooping Cough, and Measles
combined in one year. The Avengers: Infinity War could be made
17.75 times, and around 73% of Americans could get a Fenty Stunna lip paint. Come fall,
1.2 billion around the world could get a free pumpkin spice
latte. 15 million Americans could have their dental insurance covered for a year, or 543
thousand wouldn't even have to pay tax. While 142.5 million Naloxone kits could be purchased to help prevent opioid
overdoses. Feel like going green? 200 thousand homes could be fitted with solar panels, which last up to 20 years. Or,
84,000 people could get a Tesla Model S.
Change that to one of the cheaper electric cars, and 228 thousand people could be sporting a gas free vehicle.
What would other countries think?
5.7 billion is more than three times
belize's entire GDP, or you could buy more than 14 White Houses in America, which is valued at
389 million a pop. Speaking of houses,
5.7 billion could pay for every homeless person in America's rent for nine months. We could pay off the student loans of over
150,000 US graduates, cover the cost of more than a quarter of NASA's yearly budget, keep Wikipedia running for
228 years, and make every science article published in the U.S. over the next four years
open access and available freely to all, that would be pretty cool.
Of course, most economists predict that the wall will cost much more than 5.7 billion.